こんにちは和美社長でやってまいりました
コスプレコーン
さあすぎて今回の結べこっちだっ
じゃあ今回割としっかり多めになっておりますねって当て投げていきましょう
えっじゃあこれから行こうか今回はすごいよ1中ではありません
ちょっと俺も実物で初めてなんですと思いつくだけていきます
wh
うわぁ
キターなんかめっちゃっていう黄色くなったんですけどあああああこれだけで何かある
というかな
えっとまず
うわぁかるかな豚のしっぽだと思うんですけど別れたものでこれでわかるかも失敗です
けどねぇ
いやーか大根どうなんだろうなぁ
中川背中ぽいなぁこれで来たうわカルチャーわかるんですか背中のパーツでした部分
です
car
魚すごい
ああああああ
足始めたし大勢すごいなつべとかって同じく足
動い毅これをう
何これこのバカだったっけあんなんか体のうろこみたいな部分でなんとなくわかります
今ならズボンなら書く奴だ
腕なんかんもうもう俺もわからんねこれからしっぽじゃないですがうねか何かな気がし
ていましたこれこれ
ああああああ
これからと同罪だなぁ
あ備えをどう際にわたっていかにならすごい
これが間違いなく胴体ですねもう枯れてし皆さんこれ
モンスターですいやーもうハンターの皆さんだったらこの時点で気付いたでしょう
そしてこれが
ええええええ
顔面ですねーすごいで結構た際よこれでも電池いるとかがあっ
パッチ
今日ちょっと一応コスプレ3じゃないよね超きます電池いるリスト7入れてみます
電池入れましたどぅ電池に入れるっていうコスプレがすごいよねうん
という今回残ってればモンスターハンターより
な溶融水を飲んでやっていきたいと思いますずっとここ最近に息方向の人形のコスメで
ばっかりだったのでここがバシッともう
ようつく鉾判断も凝ってるとかだったら結構あったんですけどもそのモンスター地で
残ってるよ全然なくて
震えたね見たときは
暑いねー今日はトークン本当に熱いんですけど大丈夫からねっ
それだてっちゃったりするのってやばいんですけど書かがドラゴン着ぐるみファース
漬物も2期も触れコスプレ家も触れではないような骸骨ようですね本当の神様がお値段
のほう
522,900円でございま50万です
何この回かというとか不完全受注だからとタブオーダーメイドで作ってもらったんで僕
の体に合わせてほんと着だったんだと思います
暑さが心配を事だが園庭んだまだがコスプレする地健星結構あると思います
ているぞん
これは浅瀬に確定でしょうこれが確定
はいはいはい
いい
えーだってずっとこのアーモンド一人ではきれないです雪だってもらいたがいき
ましょう本当まつげてかぶって持ってる
かねぇ俺熱中そらー
今度本当にこれ
結構首のさぞいてここないけど出し授業での可能かまでっ
いいねっ
d っっ
あーなるほどねばいばーーやっぱり
あぽんキュッキュッ何度かそうねハッピーってくる
俺ね首相なくて以上ございますよ
すごく悩んでね there はサウナこの炎天下の中四つん這いになって人の喧嘩
飲めますか
神様が大変な
需要が大変なんだなぁすぐ交差ベルでしまう1回やってらんねーよ
メッツラーとをお願いしますはい
ピーターつきましたかっこいい
パターンオーダーを通っ聞いてくれつ4つ星お願いします
ん
どうぞ顔を出さないだろ
この度かを出さない方向なーっ殺す願いします配送ちゃんっ
道
g 5がみよう噛んでいません
ええええええ
持っていはい必要
いやこれでをしんどいの中高
もっともんだー
コーン竜の中
コスプレイキューことに酔う
熱中症のリスク風
全身から好きでるあ亭
すべてのコストレイヤーに注意喚起いい
[音楽]
me
食べて皆さん稲葉ランクの法人様がが幻覚前にいたらどうあどういうパンをするのか
2つ外見からお前はダースターゲット月以降
[音楽]
ません
ni ないですか
やっぱりは
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
tee
[音楽]
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
kane
wh
car
when
where
ん
me
uh
ああああああ
共感版いただきましたあどうぞ去年
wh
th
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
[音楽]